>>> NEW THIS MORNING, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
STEPHANIE GRISHAM SPEAKING OUT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A BRAND
NEW TV INTERVIEW AHEAD OF THE
RELEASE OF HER NEW BOOK
DETAILING HER TIME IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> DID PRESIDENT TRUMP ORDER YOU
NOT TO HAVE BRIEFINGS?
>> WHEN WE DISCUSSED ME TAKING
THE JOB HE ALREADY SUSPENDED THE
BRIEFINGS FOR SIX MONTHS UNDER
SARAH AND SAID HE DIDN'T THINK
WE NEEDED ANY MORE BRIEFINGS.
HE SPOKE TO THE PRESS TWO OR
THREE TIMES DIRECTLY MY JOB WAS
SO WORK MORE BEHIND THE SCENES
WITH PRINT AND REGIONAL AND
LOCAL.
>> YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
CULTURE OF CASUAL DISHONESTY AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU WERE ENABLING THAT CULTURE,
WEREN'T YOU?
>> YES, I WAS, AND I'VE
REFLECTED ON THAT AND I REGRET
THAT AND ESPECIALLY NOW WATCHING
HIM AND SO MANY PEOPLE PUSH THE
FALSE ELECTION NARRATIVE, I NOW
WANT TO IN WHATEVER WAY I CAN
EDUCATE THE PEOPLE ABOUT THE
BEHAVIORS WITHIN THE WHITE
HOUSE, BECAUSE IT DOES LOOK LIKE
HE'S GOING TO TRY TO RUN IN
2024.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE HE WILL?
>> I DIDN'T AT FIRST BUT I'M
STARTING TO BELIEVE HE WILL.
HE'S CLEARLY THE FRONT-RUNNER IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
EVERYBODY'S SHOWING THEIR FEALTY
TO HIM.
HE'S ON HIS REVENGE TOUR FOR
PEOPLE WHO DARED TO VOTE FOR
IMPEACHMENT AND I WANT TO WARN
PEOPLE ONCE HE TAKES OFFICE, IF
HE WERE TO WIN, HE DOESN'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT RE-ELECTION
ANYMORE.
HE WILL BE ABOUT REVENGE.
HE WILL PROBABLY HAVE SOME
PRETTY DRACONIAN POLICIES THAT
GO ON.
THERE WERE CONVERSATIONS A LOT
OF TIMES THAT PEOPLE WOULD SAY
THAT WILL BE THE SECOND TERM.
THAT WILL BE THE SECOND TERM,
MEANING WE WON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT A RE-ELECTION.
>> IS IT A MISTAKE TO WORK FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> YES.
>> WHY'D YOU DO IT?
>> WATCHING PEOPLE IN THE
BEGINNING REACT TO HIM, I GAVE
VOICE TO PEOPLE WHO FELT
FORGOTTEN.
MANY YOU HAVE US GOT INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND GOT HEADY WITH
POWER AND WE DIDN'T THINK ABOUT
SERVING THE COUNTRY.
IT WAS ABOUT SURVIVING IN THERE.
HE LOVED THE CHAOS AND THAT'S,
IT'S BAD AND OBVIOUSLY HINDSIGHT
IS 20/20.
I HAVE NO ALLUSIONS PEOPLE WILL
THINK I'M SO HERO.
THIS HAS NOT BEEN A FUN PROCESS,
EVEN WITH THE STATEMENT YOU JUST
READ THE LEFT DOESN'T LIKE ME,
THE RIGHT DOESN'T LIKE ME, BUT I
HAVE GONE BACK TO BASICS AND I
HAVE MY FAMILY AND I HAVE MY
FRIENDS AND PEOPLE CAN TAKE THIS
BOOK FOR WHAT IT IS.
IT'S HONEST AND THAT'S ALL I CAN
SAY.
>> JOINING US NOW IS CNN WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENT KATE
BENNETT.
IT'S JUICY.
THAT IS FOR SURE, THIS BOOK,
RIGHT?
IT'S GOT A LOT OF DETAILS IN IT.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK OF HER
COMMENTS SO FAR, KNOWING WHAT
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE BOOK, WHICH
YOU'VE READ?
>> I DO THINK IT'S INTERESTING.
SHE IS BASICALLY SAYING THIS WAS
A BAD PLACE.
THIS CONTINUES TO BE A PERSON,
SPEAKING OF FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP, WHOSE MOTIVES ARE
DRIVEN BY REVENGE OR DRIVEN BY,
YOU KNOW, WANTING TO CHANGE THE
COUNTRY IN A WAY THAT MIGHT NOT
BE ACCEPTED.
IT WAS INTERESTING WHAT SHE SAID
ABOUT THE REFRAIN, THAT WILL BE
THE SECOND TERM, THAT WILL BE
THE SECOND TERM FOR THE MORE
DRACONIAN POLICIES THAT WERE
DISCUSSED WITHIN THE WEST WING.
I THINK THE JUICY PARTS ARE THE
MOST INTERESTING, SHE WAS IN THE
ROOM MORE THAN ANY OTHER ADVISER
FOR BOTH THE PRESIDENT AND THE
FIRST LADY AND I THINK FOR ME,
READING THE BOOK, THOSE MOMENTS
OF INSIGHT INTO THE CHAOTIC
WORLD, THE DRAMA, THE REAL LIFE
"APPRENTICE-Y" FEEL IN THE WEST
WING WAS WHAT WAS INTERESTING.
>> YOU HAVE REACTION FROM THE
FORMER FIRST LADY.
>> I JUST GOT THIS FROM MELANIA
TRUMP'S OFFICE ABOUT STEPHANIE
GRISHAM.
"THE AUTHOR IS DESPERATELY
TRYING TO REHABILITATE HER
TARNISHED REPUTATION BY
MANIPULATING AND DISTORTING THE
TRUTH WILL MRS. TRUMP.
MS. GRISHAM IS A DECEITFUL AND
TROUBLED INDIVIDUAL WHO DOESN'T
DESERVE ANYONE'S TRUST."
AS STEPHANIE GRISHAM HAS SAID,
SHE'S EXPECTING THIS.
SHE'S EXPECTING THEM TO TAKE HER
DOWN AND SHE SAID, I MEAN THIS
IS THE IRONY OF THE WHOLE THING,
SHE SAID "I WAS ONCE ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WORKED ON THE INSIDE
AND TOOK OTHERS DOWN WHEN THEY
TURNED ON THE TRUMPS."
THAT WAS HER JOB OSTENSIBLY FOR
MANY YEARS.
>> SHE SAID THEY WERE "HEADY
WITH POWER" DIDN'T CARE ABOU